welcome Felice Bell and Jennifer Murphy
[Applause]
[Music]
gambling quit your job with no savings
and a rough sketch of the rest of your
life
withdraw money from your 401k pay the
penalty
why wait in this economy everything you
own is worth more than it will ever be
cut your hair
call yourself new call your ex call
Robin tell her you bought a ticket to
the bay paso robles roadtrip wine taste
buy a Malbec and a tight red tea eat a
cookie from an LA dispensary
chain smoke around bed and breakfast
hillside fire pit with San Diego
newlyweds and vineyard view go to the
water with your girls and grease-stained
bags of burgers sit on driftwood sunset
remember you folded remember your place
spend the night in Torino resent the
safety of the slots sit at the blackjack
table and the dealer rent retirement
pray God cares enough to pony up an ace
leaving lunch on Lake Tahoe they say is
deep and cold enough to preserve a body
hole railroad workers mafia military and
possibly a monster like Loch Ness no one
can prove it ignore the math odds are a
distraction what matters is the chip
count the cards on the table the cards
in your hand you must be willing to lose
when the dream was an ocean it lived in
the desert near Edwards Air Force Base
where NASA tested spaceships it fed on
cactus and stars but it kept being
delayed it's not time they said the
dream grew impatient broke water
extracted from its mother in a bed of
wrecked strawberries as a teenager it
cried took endless drives over the
grapevine out of a town ripe with
oranges and silence get me out of here
it begged it was so tiny and delicate
you feared for its life it seemed a
butterfly might land on its face and
crush it it frightened you to love
something so much later it rebelled got
drunk handcuffed for urinating whiskey
on the neighbors rose bushes the dream
had issues needs don't ignore me it
screamed it needed skyscrapers and
nicotine needed to stay home reading the
Easter Parade instead of going to its
job as a waitress at a restaurant where
could not afford the food it was a dream
for Christ's sake it had better things
to do it had to write pray dispatch
fleets of messages to God about how to
make itself known in daylight all its
life the dream made plans it planned to
write publish get rich publish have sex
with reckless attractive men in the back
seats of taxis yes that happened no it
didn't the dream argued with itself with
the truth you didn't have the dream the
dream had you every single one of its
plans fell through I give up
it cried I quit hid itself in the dark
until finally it heard its name being
called pondered the unspeakable miracle
of sticking around long enough to be
seen now it looks around for the ones
who've waited years
for its arrival they always come for you
don't they
your girls with their crossed fingers
and belief in you no destination they
say no Maps no idea where we're headed
and even though you cannot believe this
is happening
even though you are hallucinating with
fear you hear yourself say it I am ready
I'm ready let's go episode 1 everyone
always wants to know how he became
sisters how'd you two meet like we're a
married couple I like to say we met
online
we met at the Nuyorican poets cafe in
1999 every Friday night of our young
lives spent in the audience or on the
mic miss one Friday and you would hear
about the poet who killed it you should
have been there I killed it the night I
met Jeff she was sitting on the lap of
my arch-nemesis I swear we are never
going to be friends really we're not
going to be friends because I'm friends
with someone you don't like absolutely
without a doubt misdemeanor one menacing
I love it when women size me up and spit
me out before they've ever met me before
I've said one word the phrase dismissed
before investigation comes to mind
misdemeanor to fraud Felice likes to
claim she believes in science and math
that she proceeds through life with
logic like a man lot of logic in this
example a lot of fairness and justice
real open mind at play Felice is not a
detective she only plays one on stage
and when I say that I say it as a
private investigator license in the
state of New York
Sherlock Holmes doesn't need a license
he solves crime so do i using science
and my intuition
everything I know about detective work I
learned on TV episode 2 how we became
sisters right so about a year later Jen
and I were invited to read poems in the
basement of to boots pizzeria careers
had taken off after the pizzeria reading
we have a slice I don't know why but I
tell her something I hadn't told anyone
I spent the weekend in Reno with nacho
Velasquez first thing she says did you
see nachos little nacho and we were
friends that not how I remember it in my
mind we became friends after I was
diagnosed with cancer you came with me
to sloan-kettering because my family
wasn't handy okay let's hear that
version so we walk into sloan-kettering
and I have never seen my sister happier
reminder we are at the cancer hospital
there are people limping by with curved
faces and missing ears this place has
everything there is a waterfall there
are orchids little packets of graham
crackers I am sitting in the waiting
room sweating through my dress she's
making herself a cappuccino it's
delicious I cannot handle you right now
episode three six years after we first
met my childhood best friend dies the
day of his wake there is a transit
strike Jen walks from Kabul hill to
Crown Heights so she can go with me
there are moments that bond and this one
is key when there is no train no Carson
is no bus my sister will walk miles just
to be by my side when a sister loves a
sister when she says it's time for
bibimbap she means I need to talk I'm
having a meltdown
and when she says did you sleep with my
man nacho Velasquez she means I'm having
trust issues around our friendship again
you are supposed to know this when a
sister loves a sister you are in Crown
Heights and she is in bedford-stuyvesant
or you are in Spain sipping absence and
she is in Paris writing or you are in
your apartment sunglasses and hoodie
creating new choreography to the right
soundtrack well you're home having
flashbacks to 911 listening to the last
call of your friend a firefighter who
perished in the North Tower
his last words thank you you find it
difficult to say goodbye when a sister
loves a sister it is five o'clock in the
morning you are asleep and she is
calling you say hey sis did someone die
you are sobbing saying your boyfriend
the cop got shot and straight away her
voice contains the depth and calm of a
winless Lake for hours she stays on the
line and remains very quiet and very
kind whatever you need to get through
this when she says let's see each other
this week she means let's cancel and
talk on the phone instead when she says
this thing Tara brach said reminded me
of you she means it reminded her of her
and then you it means she's been doing
guided meditations again is about to
drop some spiritual wisdom type
about radical acceptance ergo the only
way to live is by accepting each minute
as an unrepeatable miracle in the 90s
you fought with the constancy of dawn it
was entertaining a sport a pastime what
is wrong with you tonight what's wrong
with you I'm not the one being
aggressive I don't know what you're
talking about I'm relaxed I'm not doing
this with you right now
you're wide-eyed friends would raise
their hands and say what is going on
with you two one winter when you had no
money you mailed her flowers from Paris
because she was having surgery one
spring in your deepest heartbreak she
stood with you in the rain on Fulton
Street
this isn't your dreams this you can
leave them one winter one spring two
decades two women one dream
your mother's names are Sheila they
quote the Bible saying you are fearfully
and wonderfully made hey boy it's good
you're done with that MSA you and your
sister laugh thank God that pesky dream
is finished now you can finally get back
to the peeling potatoes and shucking
corn when a sister loves a sister you
want her in the audience when your play
premieres at the National Theater in
Washington DC when a sister loves a
sister she cheers and screams when an
agent agrees to send out your stories
when a sister loves a sister she
celebrates your artistic romantic and
spiritual victory you are like young
girls becoming what they always dreamed
of becoming when they grew up when a
sister loves a sister you listen to her
Reeve thinking as heaven to the gods is
poetry to the beloved
[Applause]